Because it's a makeup class.
We'll do something a little special because we're going to show a clip.
A movie,
uh,
did I think is particularly appropriate out is we get into it.
I'll tell you why.
Stupid about a five minute segment from a film called the third man.
Has anyone ever seen it?
Okay.
Maybe more than I thought.
Uh,
just to set up this scene,
for those of you who have seen it more,
for those of you who haven't this,
this is a film was made in 1948,
uh,
called the third man,
from a Graham Greene short story and it takes place in post World War II,
Vienna and the clip,
we're going to see,
uh,
the most famous part of the movie,
cakes,
poster of a conversation between two old friends.
One of them played by Orson Welles,
uh,
is in a black market,
a racket in,
uh,
in Vienna,
and is making a living doing something very bad,
uh,
in the black market.
And in this scene,
he's trying to convince an old school friend of his,
uh,
played by Joseph Cotton to join a join this thing.
He is also,
I should say the Orson Welles character has also faked his death.
Uh,
so no one except his immediate,
uh,
conspirators node knows he's still alive.
I should have said that.
He's faked his death.
And here he has a scene with his old school friend played by Joseph Cotton and
he's trying to convince him to come into his black market racket.
So here,
here comes a third man,
a good sane,
and it's,
um,
it's good because I think it conveys something of the flavor of Machiavelli's
thought,
not Italy for 30 years under the Borgias.
This is Machiavelli's time,
bloodshed and murder and Leonardo Da Vinci and the renaissance for sweat under
Switzerland for 500 years' peace and democracy.
We did it,
produce the cuckoo clock.
Um,
and,
uh,
talk about that in a moment.
But I,
I want to talk begin by talking about who was Machiavelli,
how do we read the prints?
A marquee value was a Florentine,
and to know that,
uh,
is to know virtually everything you need to know about him.
Uh,
I'm exaggerating,
but,
uh,
I do.
So to make a point,
Florence was a republic.
It was a city state in Machiavelli,
spent a good deal of his adult life in the service of the republic living in
Florence,
uh,
the center of the renaissance at the height of the renaissance,
Machiavelli wished to do for politics what his contemporaries like Leonardo Da
Vinci and Michelangelo had done for art and sculptor.
In other words,
he hoped to revive in some way to spirit of the ancients of antiquity,
but to modify it in the lights of his own experience and does,
he puts it in the dedication of his most famous book.
He writes this book,
the prince is a product of long experience with modern things into continuous
reading of the ancient ones in Machiavelli,
we have what we have come to call modernity given its first and most powerful
expression,
but Machiavelli was not a,
an ordinary Florentine.
He grew up under the rule of the [inaudible] and I'd had is to say the first
family of Florence,
uh,
and live to see them deposed by a Dominican friar by the name of Savannah,
Rola Savonarola attempted to impose a kind of theocracy and Florence,
uh,
sort of Christian Republic of virtue,
but the Florentines being what they were,
uh,
rejected this idea and the rule of Savannah Rola was short lived and in its
place,
a republic was reestablished,
a where Machiavelli occupied the office of Secretary to the second chancery,
a kind of diplomatic post,
which he held for 14 years from 1498 to 15,
12.
And after the fall of the republic and the return of the meditate to princely
rule there,
Machiavelli was exiled from the city,
from politics to a smaller state that he owned on the outskirts of the city.
And you can visit it today.
And it was here from a place of political exile that he wrote his major works,
the prints,
the discourses on Livy and the art of war.
And it was from here also that he wrote voluminous letters to friends seeking
knowledge about politics.
Machiavelli was a kind of political junkie,
you could say in things happenings,
uh,
in Italy and elsewhere.
And in one of these letters,
a famous letter to his friend,
a man named Francesco Vettori,
he describes how he came to write his most famous book.
And I want to read a passage from that letter.
And it was also,
I should say on the basis of this letter with this why I asked people from time
to time to remove their caps,
uh,
in a,
in the classroom from the house of study.
This is the way Machiavelli study.
When evening comes,
he writes,
I returned to my house and go to my study at the door.
I take off my clothes of the day covered with muck and dirt,
and I put on my regal and courtly garments.
And decently reclothed I entered the ancient courts of ancient men were received
by them lovingly.
I feed on the food.
That alone is mine and that I was born for
there.
I am not ashamed to speak with them and to ask them the reasons for their
actions and they in their humanity reply to me.
And for the space of four hours every night,
I feel no boredom.
I forget every pain.
I do not fear poverty and death does not frightened me.
I deliver myself entirely unto them.
And because Dante says that to have understood without retention does not make
knowledge.
I have noted what capitol I have made from their conversations and have composed
a little work on principalities where I delve as deeply as I can into
reflections on this subject,
debating,
debating what a principality is of what kinds they are,
how they are required,
how they are maintained and what the why they are lost.
So there Matthia valley gives you,
gives us a sense of the seriousness with which he approached his subject,
how he studied and what it was he came to.
Right.
Let me just say from the beginning,
uh,
the prince is a deceptive book.
Uh,
what else would we expect from a name,
from the name of a man?
Uh,
that has become synonymous with deception.
It is a work,
the prints that everybody has heard of perhaps has some preconception about.
Uh,
I was checking the web yesterday and I found a new book about Machiavelli,
which none of these ever fail to surprise me.
This one is called the suit Machiavelli and guide to men's fashion.
Check it out.
Uh,
who knows.
Machiavelli's name is everywhere.
It is applied to everything from corporate executives how to do men's fashion.
Everybody knows or thinks they know what his work is about.
His name again,
is synonymous with deception,
treachery,
cunning deceit.
Just look at the cover of your book.
Look at his face,
look at his smile.
Really more of a smirk.
Uh,
he seems to be saying,
I know something you don't know.
The difficulty with reading Machiavelli today is that we all think we already
what he knows,
and that is false.
Mocking your valley was a revolutionary
in the preface to his largest book,
the discourses on Livy.
He compares himself with Chris to Christopher Columbus for his discovery of what
he calls new modes and orders would Columbus had done for geography.
Machiavelli claims he will do for politics.
That is to say discover an entirely new continent,
a new world,
so to speak,
the new world of Machiavelli,
Machiavelli's new world.
His new modes and orders will require clearly a displacement of the earlier one
of the previous one.
When Machiavelli wrote,
of course,
the dominant form of political organization was the empire,
or to speak more precisely the Christian empire,
the Holy Roman Empire.
It was,
it was known in the time of Machiavelli was the successor to the ancient Roman
state,
the older Roman Empire.
Both of these empires had aspired to a kind of universality,
and this universality was given expression in Dante is famous treatise,
the Monarchia of monarchy that set out a model for a universal Christian state
based on the unity and oneness of the human race.
Under a Christian ruler,
Machiavelli rejected this idea of the empire in harked back instead to the model
of Republican Rome.
And there is much in his writing that recalls the sort of extraordinary virtues
and capacities of the citizens of the ancient Republican city state.
But you might say just as Machiavelli broke with the dominant model of Christian
universalism,
so too did he reject the ancient model of the small autonomous republican state.
He makes this clear in a famous passage at the beginning of chapter 15 of the
prints,
and I just wanted to read that passage as well
here.
Machiavelli's tears,
I depart from the orders of others.
I depart from their modes,
he says,
but since it is my intent to write something useful to whoever understands it,
it has appeared to me more fitting to go directly to the effectual of truth of
things then to the imagination of it.
In many have imagined when things here of Plato perhaps,
but also to Christianity,
many of imagined republics and principalities that have never been seen or known
to exist in truth for it is far from how one lives to how one should lives.
That he who lets go of what is done for what should be done learns his ruling
rather than his preservation.
In other words,
no cities,
no platonic cities and speech,
no Augustinian cities of God.
Uh,
we will only look,
he says to the effectual truth of things,
the effectual truth of the matter,
not the imagination of it or the utopia of it.
That passage is often taken to be the beginning of Chapter 15,
the essence of machiavellian realism,
a kind of rail politic as it were.
His appeal from the art to the is to take one's bearings again from the
effectual truth of things.
Just uh,
this seems to be in many ways the essence of his teaching to be sure.
And Machiavelli focuses on key aspects of political reality,
which are often ignored by thinkers like Plato and Aristotle,
murders,
conspiracies,
coup d'etat.
These are the kinds of political phenomenon phenomena.
He is interested.
He seems to be more interested in the evils that human beings do.
Then the goods to which they aspire.
You might even say that Machiavelli takes delight in demonstrating,
much to our Chagrin,
the space between our lofty intentions and the actual consequences of our deeds.
And yet it would seem to me there is more to Machiavelli valley then the term
realism connotes.
Although that is certainly important
in this passage,
Machiavelli announces his brake,
indeed,
his repudiation of all those who have come before,
all those who have come before
he both replaces and yet reconfigures according to his own lights,
elements from both the Christian Empire in the Roman republic to create a new
form of political organization,
distinctly his own,
what we might call today the modern state Machiavelli is the founder did
discover the inventor of the modern state.
This modern secular sovereign state was refined and developed in the decades and
centuries after Machiavelli and the writing of hubs of lock of Rousseau,
just say nothing of contemporary 20th century writers from both the right and
the left mocks vapor.
Carl Schmidt to a man and Italian philosopher named Antonio Gramsci.
Yeah.
Who was the author of a book,
interestingly called the modern prints based on Machiavelli himself,
Machiavelli's state itself,
universalist ambitions in many ways,
much like it's Christian and Roman predecessors,
but this is a state he believes that has now been liberated or at least or
emancipated from Christian and classical conceptions of virtue.
The management of affairs is left to those people who he calls princess,
which is the machiavellian usage,
designates a new kind of political founder or leader endowed with a new species
of ambition,
love of glory and elements of Prophetic Authority that we might call charisma.
Okay,
but just what was the nature of the revolution contemplated by our founder,
Machiavelli,
the founder of modern political science?
Consider just for a moment the title in dedication of the book,
the prince appears on its surface to be a most conventional work.
It presents itself in the long tradition of what has come to be called the
mirror of princes.
Books that give a kind of guide to the do's and don'ts of princely behavior.
Fair enough.
It seems to go back a long,
long time.
And the appearance of conventionality is supported by the opening words of the
book in his dedicatory letter.
The first words are first line out of his mouth are,
the first lines are,
it is customary.
He says,
it is a work intended to ingratiate himself to Lorenzo de Medici,
the man to whom the work is dedicated accustomary prints a traditional prince
who has just regained his power.
But look again,
consider the structure of the first three chapters.
All States,
all dominions that have held in do hold empire over men are either republics are
principalities.
He says in the opening sentence of chapter one
have distinguished two kinds of two and only two kinds of regimes,
republics and principalities as the only ones worth mentioning.
He goes on to distinguish two kinds of principalities.
There are hereditary principalities like those,
uh,
currently run by Lorenzo,
which are required,
which acquire their authority through tradition and bloodlines,
hereditary blood lines.
And then he says there are new princes in new principalities.
Machiavelli then asserts that his book will deal only with principalities
leaving.
He says the discussion of republics for elsewhere.
What one is tombs is discourses on Livy,
which he was already writing by this time.
But then Machiavelli goes home to tell the reader that the exclusive subject of
this book,
the entire exclusive subject will be the new prints.
In other words,
not Lorenzo at all,
but precisely princes who have or will chew,
achieve Dera Authority through their own guile,
their own force or their own veer to,
to use the famous machiavellian term that I want to talk about later.
The true,
in other words,
recipient of this book must be necessarily the potential plants.
That is to say someone with sufficient political audacity to create their own
authority,
who is not simply received it from the past,
but to create their own authority.
Maybe one could even say Machiavelli's prince is in a way the first truly self
made man.
So what then is the character of this new prints and how does he differ from
more conventional modes of princely or political authority?
And in one of the most famous chapters of the book,
chapters six entitled of New principalities that are acquired to one's own arms
and virtue.
There's that word again,
veer to one own arms and virtue.
Machiavelli discusses the character of the modern prints,
the new prints,
a prudent man he writes,
should always enter upon the pads beaten by great men,
and imitate those who have been most excellent so that if its own virtue does
not reach that far,
it at least is in the odor of it.
We at least come within,
you might say,
sniffing distance of their greatness.
Once you do,
he says,
what Archer's do when attempting to reach a distant target,
namely aim your bow high,
knowing that the force of gravity will bring the Arrow down.
In other words,
set your sights high knowing you will probably fall short.
So who are the greatest examples?
He says of princely rule that the prudent man,
interesting choice of words the prudent man should imitate.
Okay.
And here Machiavelli gives a list of those heroic founders of peoples in states,
Moses,
Cyrus,
Romulus,
Theseus,
and so on.
It's one examines their actions and lives.
He writes,
one does not see that they had anything else from fortune.
Then the opportunity which you gave them,
the matter enabling them to introduce any form they pleased.
Notice in that sentence he uses those areas Tutelian terms form and matter that
we spoke about in relation to the Aristotelian regime.
They had nothing else from fortune.
He says again,
then the opportunity,
the occasion that gave them the matter,
enabling them to introduce any farm they pleased.
In short Machiavelli claims,
these were founders who created in a way ex Nihilo out of nothing.
They only had the occasion and a kind of formless matter upon which they could,
uh,
adopt and impose any farm they took.
And they had of course,
the strength of mind as well as the audacity and cunning to take advantage of
this situation.
Such opportunities.
He writes such occasions,
made these men successful and they're excellent virtue enabled the opportunity
to be recognized.
Hence their father lands were ennobled by it and they became prosperous.
They took advantage of their opportunity,
seized their opportunity and impose their own farm up upon it.
And it is here that Machiavelli introduces his famous distinction between armed
and unarmed profits.
All the armed profits,
he says,
conquered and the unarmed were ruined.
This seems to be,
and,
and is clearly a kind of classic statement of share,
Machiavellian power,
politics.
All politics grows out of the barrel of a gun is a famous 20th century
Machiavellian.
Uh,
once put it,
uh,
on the armed crossfits conquer the unarmed lose,
but there seems to be more to it than this.
Uh,
Machiavelli compares the prince to a profit.
Why does he use that language?
What is a profit?
Uh,
the most obvious answer is a person to whom God speaks.
Machiavelli's armed profits,
uh,
may not be religious figures and they are not necessarily recipients of divine
knowledge,
but they seem to be,
at least on his account,
people have exceptional personal qualities that allow them to bring laws to be
law bringers law givers,
shapers of institutions,
and also reformers of opinions,
uh,
that govern our lives.
Machiavelli's armed profit is more than just a gangster like Orson Welles and
that part he is a teacher.
And to kind of educator,
uh,
as well,
you might even think in your class and your sections.
How or in what ways does Machiavelli's armed profit differ in important ways?
Both from Plato's philosopher King as well as Aristotle's notion of the
[inaudible] as their sort of magnanimous statesman.
Although this kind of talk about armed profits always when is characteristic of
Machiavelli.
He likes this kind of tough talk.
Uh,
he clearly recognizes that there are clear exceptions to his rule about armed
profits.
Who comes to mind most vividly,
who in other words is not present in Machiavelli's list of great profits that
one should imitate?
Yes,
most of hobbyists perhaps certainly to his contemporaries.
Jesus who triumphed through words in teaching alone.
He had no troops.
He had no arms.
He established a religion first,
a sect you might say,
than a religion.
Then eventually an empire,
the holy Roman Empire that was established in the name of that teaching words
may well be a powerful weapon,
uh,
as powerful as a gun.
And then you might say,
what is Machiavelli himself?
What is the teaching of who is Machiavelli?
But an archetypal unarmed profit.
He has no troops.
He has no territory.
He controls no real estate.
He's been banished.
Yet he is clearly attempting to conquer,
comparing himself to Columbus to conquer in large part to the transformation of
our understanding of good and evil,
a virtue and vice in order.
In other words,
to make people obey you,
you must first make them believe,
you know,
prophetic.
Machiavelli's prophetic prints,
in other words,
must have some of the qualities of a philosopher as well as a religious reformer
trying to reshape and remold human opinion is specially opinion over,
as we say,
good and evil,
just and unjust.
What does this reformation,
so to speak or transformation consist of?
You might even call this Machiavelli in the garden of good and evil,
midnight in the garden of good and evil for Machiavelli.
Okay,
one,
uh,
point often
I attributed about Machiavelli is that he introduced a new kind of in moralism
into politics
in that famous chapter,
Chapter 15,
he says,
he sets out to teach the prince.
How not to be good
striking formulation.
He will teach the prince how not to be good and it perhaps the most important
book on Ana Machiavelli ever written.
The author of that book declared Machiavelli to be a teacher of evil,
like what to think about that a teacher of evil is that what is all he was
questions of good and bad
virtue and vice appear on virtually every page of the prince.
He is not simply a teacher of political pragmatism of how to adjust means to fit
the ends.
He seems to be offering nothing short of a comprehensive revolution
transformation.
If you want to use the Nietzschean language,
Trans Valuation of our most basic vocabulary about good and evil,
Machiavelli doesn't reject the idea of the good.
Rather he redefines it.
He's continually speaking and in fact,
I would suggest and virtually every page of the book,
he's continually speaking the language of virtue is word veer to which a word
that retains the Latin root for the word man.
Vere,
we're man and veer to a word that is perhaps best translated or by our word
manliness.
What distinguishes Machiavelli's use of this language of veer to manliness is
that he's six two located in certain extreme situations such as political
foundings,
changes of regimes,
wars,
both domestic and foreign kinds.
What distinguishes Machiavelli from his predecessors in many ways is his attempt
to take the extra ordinary situation.
The extreme situation can the extremes of political founding,
conspiracies wars,
coups is takes them,
is the normal situation,
and then makes morality fit that extreme.
His examples are typically drawn from situations of human beings or politics in
extremists with the very survival or independence of a society is at stake.
In those situations you might say,
and only in those situations is it permissible to violate the precepts of
ordinary morality.
In those situations,
one must learn as he says,
how not to be good,
to have to violate the conventions in cannons of ordinary morality.
Machiavelli takes his bearings from these extreme states of emergency and in his
own way,
six,
to normalize them,
to present them as as the normal condition of politics.
Machiavelli's preference for these extreme situations expresses his belief that
only in moments of great crisis with the very existence of a state is it risk?
Does human nature truly reveal itself?
We finally or fully understand what people are only in the most extreme
situations.
The paradox that you know,
might say,
runs throughout all of Machiavelli's,
uh,
morality
is it the very possibility of group virtue grows out of,
and in fact is even dependent upon the context of chaos,
violence,
and disorder that always threatens political world.
Think of it,
I mean,
think of many of our great political models or heroes.
What would the Duke of Marlborough has been without Louie the 14th.
What would Washington has been without George the third?
What would Lincoln has been without the slave interest?
What would,
Churchill has been without Hitler?
In other words,
his point is that good is only possible because of the prior existence of bad.
Good is founded upon evil and even the greatest goods.
The founding and preservation of cities often require a murder.
Yeah.
What was Romulus is murder of remiss or canes?
Murder of Abel,
but a kind of murder,
uh,
that founded that at the basis of the founding of cities and civilizations.
One thinks in a way of wells as line.
And the third man when he looks down from above and said,
says,
uh,
if I gave you 20,000 pounds for every dot that stopped moving,
would you really tell me to keep my money requires for Machiavelli?
The founding of regimes requires that kind of cold and cruel calculation.
Of course,
it's being used in the movie just to support a criminal enterprise.
No,
not the founding of a city.
And you might,
we might investigate that as well,
but Machiavelli does not deny that in ordinary times and what we might call
times of normal politics,
the ordinary rules of justice prevail.
He also shows however it normal politics is itself dependent upon extra ordinary
politics,
periods of crisis and arche instability revolution where the normal rules of the
game are suspended.
It is in these times,
you might say,
when individuals have extraordinary virtue in capacity,
prophetic qualities is,
he calls it in chapter six,
are most likely to emerge
while the Aristotelian statesmen just to make a contrast for a moment is most
likely to value stability and the necessary to achieving it.
The machiavellian prints seeks war because it is only,
again,
in the most extreme situations that one can prosper and be prosperous.
Think about the lines again from the movie,
uh,
under,
for 30 years under the Borsch eyes,
violence,
murder,
terror,
bloodshed,
but what did it produce greatness of an unprecedented type stability,
democracy and brotherly love,
peace.
What does that produce mediocrity,
the cuckoo clock?
There might be a little more of nature suggested and that then,
then Machiavelli,
but I think the machiavellian overtones are,
are very evident.
I mean,
consider just the following.
Every child,
every one of you,
every one of us was brought up to know that one must never do wrong,
even if good consequences are seeing to follow.
It is never right to give bad examples to others,
even if one expects good to come from it.
Hit.
Machiavelli breaks these rules about not giving bad examples.
Virtue is not associated with the classical conceptions of moderation,
of justice,
if self control or what the Christian virtues of faith,
hope and charity,
virtual virtual means for him if kind of manly self assertion,
audacity ruthlessness,
a reliance on one's own arms and calculated use of cruelty to achieve ones.
And
the model of Machiavellian veer too is the renaissance statesmen and General
Cesare Borgia.
And it's very interesting that Orson Welles made a movie not so often seem today
about Cesare Borgia.
I want to leave you with reading one passage from the prince chapter seven in
which Machiavelli illustrates the kind of veer to uh,
Cesare represented and that he wants to recommend for those who follow him
once the Duke,
that's Cesare himself.
Once the Duke had taken over the Romania,
an area outside of Florence,
he founded,
had been commanded by impotent lords who had been ready to disk readier to
despoil their subjects than to correct them and given their subject subject
matter for disunion not union.
So Cesare put there,
he says,
Messer,
Ramiro d Yorko accrual and ready man.
To whom he gave the fullest power.
So Cesare set up as a lieutenant of his to impose order on this area and to whom
he delegated to the fullest responsibility.
In short time he goes on Ramiro reduced it to piece in unity with v with the
very greatest reputation for himself.
Then the Duke judge that such excessive authority was not necessary because he
feared it might become hateful and he set up a sort of civil court in the middle
of the province with the most excellent president where each city had its
advocate and because he knew that the past rigors had generated some hatred for
a mural to purge the spirits of that people into gain them entirely to himself.
He wishes to show that if any cruelty he had been committed,
this had not come from him,
from Cesare,
but from the harsh nature of his minister.
And having seized this opportunity,
get,
get that language,
sees the occasion,
seize this opportunity.
He had him placed one morning and the Piatsa in two pieces with a piece of wood
and a bloody knife beside him.
He had him cut into the bloody knife and a piece of wood behind beside him the
ferocity of this spectacle.
Machiavelli concludes left the people at once satisfied and stupefied,
and that of course is Machiavelli's veer to princely virtue.
What you do to leave the people satisfied and stupefied what we might call
today,
shock and awe.
Okay,
next week we'll continue this learning math.